the bears plan is a lot cleaner than
that yes they paid eight figures to andy
dalton but when they made the move from
20 to 11 on draft night to get justin
fields it became clear that at some
point it's going to beat justin fields
ball game here is fields and coach matt
nagy from the weekend talking about
the possibility of fields becoming the
starting quarterback
as a competitor
you're always out to
perform your best
and anytime you've stepped into a
program you've been thinking about
winning
the starting quarterback job do you take
that same mentality as you start rookie
minicamp and all these offseason
workouts that
you're going to do everything you can to
win the starting quarterback job
of course i mean i think everybody on
our team should be striving for a
starting job and if you're not then
there's no reason for you to be here so
um of course i'm gonna do everything
that i can to you know get that starting
job and
you know um it's it's really you know
it's it's it's not up to me you know
coach maggie has a set plan on you know
my development and and stuff like that
but i'm just gonna you know work hard
and keep my head down and just just just
keep grinding it out every day will
fields get any first team reps between
now and week one
right so what i would say is this is um
as we work through with justin and where
he's at with this offense we know that
it's going to take a little bit of time
here in this off-season as we get into
training camp and so we're you know
andy is the starter andy's gonna get the
one reps and what we're telling justin
and nick to do is make sure that they're
doing everything they can to try to be
that guy and and that's that competition
part and
i know that for everybody the biggest
question is is when is is that going to
happen when you go up to draft a
quarterback
like justin everyone's very excited and
they want to know when when and and
trust me we all understand that but we
need to make sure that whatever that
plan is that we put together that it's
the best thing for for the chicago bears
and and i think the easiest way to for
all of us to simply think of this is
it'll all happen for those quarterbacks
they'll all play however they're
supposed to play and we're all going to
see whatever we're supposed to see and
then it's our job as evaluators of who
they are what their strengths and
weaknesses are to make sure that we're
doing everything we can to make the
bears the best team possible that's it
i'm glad he put it that way what's in
the best interest of the bears well on
draft night it was in the best interest
of the bears to move from 20 to 11 give
up a first round pick next year and a
fourth round pick and a fifth round pick
to make that flip-flop so if it's in the
best interest of the bears to go up nine
spots and give up all that extra draft
capital to get justin fields you assume
it's in the best interest of the bears
to get the guy ready and get him on the
field but at the same time you don't
want to
accelerate to the point where it becomes
detrimental and i do believe they
some teams like to
put a guy farther down on the depth
chart so he can build some confidence as
he passes right falls as he passes andy
dalton because at the end of the day all
due respect andy dalton if you can't
beat out andy dalton why in the hell are
the 11th overall pick in the draft yeah
that's right i mean you know again that
they can preach page patience here
there's no doubt hey we know like you're
saying justin fields has more pure
raw talent than andy does and can
definitely do things where we'd go whoa
that's special andy dalton can't do that
it's gonna be about everything we talked
about in the draft though and i think
that's where matt nagy is trying to just
like
probably smooth things over i think most
people viewed justin fields as a guy
that hey need some polish need some work
as a passer and do those type of things
to where
that's where i think nagi is trying to
keep pressure off the situation just to
hey let's let this guy you know buy some
time get used to playing here get the
offense do all of those type of things
but i think ultimately
like i'm with you i just think it's a
matter of time too when you make that
type of move those type of assets you
know it's not andy dalton he's not the
future you know what he is i mean i
would think that as long as justin
fields
just is is in the mix as the talk of you
know starting week or starting and being
in that conversation that i i would make
that move if i'm chicago but i don't
know where that's going to go and
they're going to evaluate it and we'll
see how justin feels does
and and the bears are not tucked into
the nine game cluster at 1 pm eastern
week 1 they have a prime time date with
the rams which makes their situation
even more conspicuous whoever is
starting it's going to be a big topic
and if it's dalton on the field that
night there's going to be a lot of talk
about fields there's going to be a lot
of shots of fields on the sideline and
if fields is playing well he better be
ready to go and with andy dalton look
this is a guy who came in started right
away because carson palmer quit on the
bengals back in 2011 took the team to
five straight playoff berths but he's
never been in this situation where he's
been pushed hard from behind the closest
he came was when aj mccarron showed up
and and and you know played pretty well
when dalton broke his thumb trying to
make a tackle after an interception
do you see
a viable possibility here that being
pushed like this from behind will nudge
andy dalton to a higher level i i don't
think so i don't i just i think we know
we've seen we know what andy dalton's
all about at this point yeah it's a good
arm it's a pretty good athlete you know
but it's it's not anything great or
special that way so he's a real
professional you know he's got he's
played a lot of big moments he's battle
tested he's played in the end of big
time football games and come through a
number of times to help his team win all
of those type of things but no i think
this is like
specifically one that's truly about just
justin fields and where he is at his
development and you know the other thing
i'll say in like
justin fields defense as compared to
let's say a trey lance listen
shanahan's a genius matt nagy nobody is
saying that right now
right with trey lance in that situation
all right the other thing is is like the
49ers offense and everything they got
they got
they're set when you look at their other
10 guys on their offense it's an nfl
all-star team i mean kittle use check
trenton williams ayu dibo samuel mostert
i mean holy crap maybe the one of the
best offensive lines in football
chicago's got to be a little careful too
just to first go like like wait let's
how are we going to be offensively what
are we going to do on this side of the
ball is our offense good enough that we
feel like we can put a rookie in there
and things won't fall apart so there is
going to be a little bit of a different
assessment i think you know as far as
fields in that situation
uh chicago as compared to trey lance
with the 49ers and a team that's in the
super bowl window
yeah i think that's a great point and
look you've got a lot of jobs in chicago
this year or next year riding on whether
or not justin fields becomes the guy and
you know to the extent
that
ryan pace and matt nagy got ownership to
buy into this trade-up giving up next
year's first round pick to address a
quarterback
my first reaction was this means these
guys have two years yeah so so why do
you want to rush it if the final exam is
what does justin fields become why do
you want to rush it and potentially
screw it up you're going to want to take
your time because this year becomes a
scholarship year 2022 becomes the year
that you got to prove that justin fields
is the guy in order to stick around
beyond that i think that's a i think you
take into account
i think that's spot on mike
i think you're right and that buttons it
up pretty pretty damn good right there
but i i think that's uh certainly a part
of it and i do think it gives them you
know like you're saying a redshirt year
here to kind of get him ready and it all
make it about 20 22.
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports